all right next up this is a very
important story i know you hate traffic
it's so funny because there's nothing
you really hate in the world except for
listen when i say this word traffic
okay well i i actually hate traffic too
anyone else it's just like it turns a
nice person into an angry person well
listen to this uh upi reports a man in
washington state shout out to my home
state washington was pulled over for
using the hov lane with a skeleton in a
hoodie
writing in the passage that's an actual
picture
and not a bad job buddy i have to say
got away with it but i think you know
finally did get pulled over every time
i'm in a uh like a a mall and i see
those mannequins i'm like
do you know what's funny first of all
this person i know it's wrong i totally
get it
love your rebellion and your craftiness
and your illegal ways sure however i
don't like the hov lane it's pardo name
law i don't it's not one i opt for i
like to zig and zag i don't don't trap
me you're trapping me in the lane oh i
love that
i love it drew no
oh i ride in that h of alien and i just
look at the people who are stuck like
but have you ever been stuck in the hov
lane and you see everyone sailing past
you
yes i have drew but i don't want to talk
about it
i'm not an hov laner but i'm super into
this story and it's naughty and i can
appreciate it
[Music]
you